winning a gold medal back in the day in
Montreal and a six-time world champion
Olympic gold medalist and a guy who have
been eager to have on the show in studio
for quite some time so I'm thrilled to
have here in person Sugar Ray Leonard
good to see you sir hey rich how you
doing I was just saying brockman the
last time I saw this man I've told him
backstage as well sharing a flight back
from London a couple of Springs ago and
you got to meet my whole family on the
plane and they behaved right my kids
behave great okay thank you they were
great so want to confirm that when
you're flying 13 hours with three
children under the age of 10 it could be
a little dicey but back then you didn't
have iPads to give to them to get
through it well you know you know and
now my kid is my son is six three I met
him on the fuse fire yeah yeah
my daughter has you know it's 22 it's I
don't what's happening are we getting
older or well I think we some are
getting older you you haven't aged a day
you're right you have not aged today
let's get into it I know what we're
gonna talk about your foundation we're
gonna talk about so much going on but
let's talk about your work with the zone
right off the bat you were at Madison
Square Garden for the joshua andy ruiz
junior shocker what in the world was
that like to see in person Sugar Ray
Leonard it was stunning it was shocking
to say the least I just knew that Joshua
would just wipe him out after the two
round three realms at the field out
process we all do until we get to feel
him out and then drop the bomb mm-hmm
that didn't happen
they went the other way around in terms
of dropping the hammer
I mean Ruiz hit him and knocked him down
four times I mean I could not believe
what what happened but when I look at
release and again don't judge a book by
it's cover you look at really Louise's
like a slob I mean he looks unhealthy
see to us he talks with coppers
and the things he was saying like I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that I don't
think anyone believed that he had a
chance but himself
Li's felt he had a chance to win oh he
was going to win well let me put it this
way trying to put it in perspective did
you ever walk into the ring thinking
that you are not physically superior
than the guy that you were fighting at
all no you know this happens normally
with the favorite the champion hmm
because those fights like release is
called tuna fights mm-hmm keep you busy
keep you active and what-have-you
we get in shape the champions get in
shape but we we don't we don't have the
eye of the tiger
we're not as focused there was no fear
and what happens is like you get hit
especially in the heavyweight division
that pretty sure pretty much changes
things around
mm-hmm and it seemed the way that he
reacted afterwards was bizarre Joshua I
mean not Ruiz although putting on a
Knicks jersey and saying you're a
champion that that's odd in a way but
the the Joshua reaction afterwards what
was that like to you
Sugar Ray Leonard that to was rather
strange bizarre but then again I I
really thought about it gave us a few
days to think about it because that but
that's just him that's cuz that's his
personality but he was smiling but he
didn't I don't think he really knew his
reaction because he was shocked - mm-hmm
by being put down what - three times he
never got started Joshua never got
started and the only time I experienced
something like that nature was when I
fought Kevin Howard one of my many
comebacks 90 nothing was 8 1984 and I
got in the ring with this guy who was
never considered a threat there was no
fear and we don't have fear of you
opponent or respect of your opponent
that can get you in trouble so he
knocked you down yes yeah you'd have to
say that
I mean we bring you paint the pictures
okay understood
okay no he knocked me and he hurt me do
it and Kevin how it was never in shape I
got in that ring and all of a sudden the
first punch II through was a jab that's
it
that hurt I just wasn't I was I was
civilized in that ring and you're not
you you should be yeah I be civilized in
that statement uncivilized uncivil
square yeah you get into that ring and
we have one thing in mind is to defeat
your opponent or your opposition and I
mean that is the most frightening
experience even when you're walking
towards the ring from the dressing room
hmm you know if I write them in there
that isn't you don't have it that day
because if you're not a hundred percent
especially as a champion there could be
some strange things taking place Sugar
Ray Leonard here in the Rich Eisen show
and it to me didn't seem like Joshua
knew where he was it seemed like he was
a little bit out of it but then to see
him smiling and taking photographs with
the ruies was was strange
we had Tyson Fury in that very chair
last week Sugar Ray and he said he
thought he'd gave up would you agree
with that assessment I don't I don't
quit I don't think he gave up he just
didn't care that makes sense
he wasn't G wasn't there he was not
there and I and I was looking trying to
observe was taking place because I think
I thought he was gonna be moving around
and feel now he never did it he was just
not into the fight hmm
what do you make of Furion Wilder if
they get back together in the ring as it
expected what do you think of that
dagger but that too that too rich was a
major shocker because you know he he was
as big as he is he was it was a good
movement and punches and everything and
when he was knocked down by Wilder I
thought was over I said this is it he
got back up and he won or would make
brown closer do you think he got a
couple extra seconds to get back up
I mean that could have been I don't
think so I don't think so he got very
upset when I suggested that no more
upset than me reminding you of what
might have happened in your fight back
in 1984 he did not like that suggestion
at all like he didn't like it in the
fact that of everything that he's been
through and he started talking about the
the journey that he's been through and
and the the upbringing and the fight
back and what was going on with his
addiction what was going on with his
mental health he's basically said he
thought about all that and he got his
ass up from that canvas Theory got my
props getting up from a punch that wild
through Wow because while he hit you
it's pretty most part it's pretty much
over and theory got up and then competed
the you know for that round if I had to
give you a choice fury Wilder Joshua and
I let's even throw Ruiz jr. in there the
best fighter who do you think is that's
the one that should have all the belts
that's the one that's gonna eventually
dominate the heavyweight division
separate themselves from that class
well Sugar Ray Leonard what do you think
I mean thought I'm just just trying to
look at both look at each fighter and
judge them by what they what I think
they have yeah way I'm all on a scale
not figurative not literally but
figuratively I don't think Wilder Wilder
right now at this moment the question
you ask me I say Wilder right now
because first of all he still undefeated
he still the champions this and that the
other guys have to prove themselves and
I'll tell you what the competition is
great when you win a fight like that
with with Wilder and then that gives you
so much confidence and without
confidence you have no you have no
chance mm-hmm he's he's just I'm excited
to see what the heavyweight division has
but
common obviously the zone is now right
there I mean that was a big night for
four days on which you are part of right
there in the middle of all that that was
a big night for for the for the service
for the app and for everyone who might
not have known what it was but certainly
does now that's for sure you don't but
those kind of things don't happen all
the time
and it was it was such a again I keep
using the same word shot and it was a
shocker I mean the place just like what
I thought it's in went quiet this is
what what's happened what happened they
haven't once kept saying what happened
what happened unbelievable fight Sugar
Ray Leonard here on the Rich Eisen show
a few more minutes left with him here in
person it's to do triple G 1 by knockout
over the weekend and said he's ready for
Canelo Alvarez Oscar De La Hoya who is
Canelo's promoter and manager had this
to say on Twitter I want to read it out
for you right here nice comeback when
now fight a real fighter win a belt and
I'll consider doing the third fight
hashtag Canelo is your boss what do you
think of that Sugar Ray Leonard that
sounds good it sounds good I mean it's
it's hard for me because what would
oscar is seen in he's the promoter he's
the guy and he makes those decisions do
I want to see the fight take place yes I
want to see the fight take place rematch
yes because back in in my era my time
you know if we lose a fight we want to
we want a rematch
if there's a draw absolutely rematch it
wasn't as much but there's so much more
on the table from a monetary standpoint
it's that why you fought Duran three
times that's the only one you fought
three times yeah I mean I did I fought
Duran the third time not because I
wanted to but it was for it put me on
another tax bracket gonna do all that
yeah but Duran Duran that fight was you
know we naturally pass out prom
I like I guess almost like 50 60
stitches no but oh I did oh yeah he I
was a mess
but I got a good doctor mm-hmm who sew
me up
what's your relation you would like to
ran now I love the man you know we were
together and respect I mean we're
looking to do a kind of a not
documentary or a series of song with the
four of us with Hagler Hearns Duran
Munson and like Duran is on board
Tommy's on board I'm on board
Hagler still was still waiting for a
phone call
why why is that he feels that I'm
setting him up for something he said
really yeah because the you know for the
fight I kind of sit I did set things up
but that's back in the day
I know but yeah hopefully he Marvin I
Love You Man
pick up the phone what so is there
anybody that you walked into the ring
and and had just even as quick tinge of
fear that he might physically overpower
you you know or hurt you in fear for
fighters to say fear it's kind of it's
awkward but I understand that fusion
works but it was fear when I fought
Hagler when I came back because in
training camp I was sharp and this and
that but training camp is a whole
different thing than fighting the real
fight so I got in the ring with Hagler
and the bell rung and I'm shaking like a
leaf and I did that it still works
mm-hmm and I and that was made me you
know gave me confidence enough to go the
distance
well I got to be honest with you I would
have guessed that you would say Hagler
when asking you that question well how
does it I was fearful for you watching
that fight yeah cuz you hadn't fought in
a while yeah and Hagler just he just
looked like I mean you know what you
know and just like somebody who could
hurt he just know just looked like a
dangerous man with his fell my thing was
psychological because I
press conference I say you know what
it's a shame you got I thought Hackl
just say just a slugger this man's a
better boxer I kept saying that every
time every press conference
mmm the last press conference Hagler
said one thing he said you know what I
may surprise everybody
I'm a I'll box him I said I got him cuz
I put in his a plan to see in his head
that he didn't have to go out with me
like he did Tommy Hearns
he could wait box and show people what
he can do is that why he's not calling
you back so I mean that's not true
that's not true
okay and he went away he went he went
till I think he moved away to Milan
Italy
Hagler did not wanted a rematch okay I
did well what not right I know exactly
what it would take did beat him Sugar
Ray Leonard here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk about the Sugar Ray Leonard
foundation raises money for pediatric
type 1 and 2 diabetes research and care
helping children lead healthier more
productive lives through diet and
exercise recently a 10 year anniversary
for you yeah that relations on that
thank you so much and welcome feel good
my father was a diabetic my friends
they're either the kids called
themselves a diabetic and my wife and I
started this foundation up 10 years ago
and just wanted to give back I'm a
blessed man and you know what it's time
to reciprocate and that's blood that's
what we put together over three million
dollars has been raised for diabetes
research care in a way yes but yes
amazing figure just that amazing figures
unbelievable my dear friends support me
all the time I mean from eddie murphy i
mean i goes on down online when did you
first meet Eddie Murphy oh I met Eddie
many many years ago when I was living
back east when he was doing Saturday
Night Live yeah yeah right the back that
far yeah I was living in Maryland at the
time and all my friends they are so
supportive and I love them
thanks guys yeah I could see I saw that
Caitlyn Jenner recently came out I
imagine you met Caitlyn in Montreal you
go back to the six games 76 games yeah
he's one she's wonderful and it's it's
it's it's been a dream come true for me
cuz well I'd do something like that
especially for kids it's all about the
Keisei kids to me I'm there I'm at the
front door that's amazing that's good
for you man and I'm thrilled that you
are here on the show before I let you go
and I don't know if you have the answer
to this or not or haven't have a stories
or cosell story a howard cosell story
that you could share Howard Cosell you
know how it goes yeah how was my dear
friend and I remember when he's bought
the book he wrote his book I never
played the game I know play the game
yeah I read that book cause yeah I'm
behind this microphone in many ways
because I idolized him right watching
him on Monday Night Football learning
about what happened with him and
Muhammad Ali and the relationship that
they had and the and the backing that he
gave him and then just is his style I
just being a kid growing up in the 70s
he and Marv Albert where they were the
guys that basically caused me to want to
think about sports casting that's why I
asked you about it no because how would
you know when I when I decided to fight
Hagler but the place the world was crazy
and how it was one he said you can't win
you can't this I said well how he same
thing with your book even book this one
said don't write and you still wrote it
he said well you got me I never played
the game and that play guy was the name
of the book yes I know
thanks for coming on sugar really
appreciate it oh thanks come back
anytime seriously any of the fights that
you do in Ford is own anything I can do
to help out with the foundation you just
let me know and I'm there you'd be there
next year you got it and I'll see okay I
love it thank you thank you so much
Sugar Ray Leonard foundation you could
learn more about it by a following Sugar
Ray on Twitter at Sugar Ray Leonard also
his Instagram as well for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app